[Music]
since the war in Ukraine broke out just
over a year ago more than 8 million
people have fled the country for safety
for one third grader Margot vastuva and
her mother the journey would take them
from Ukraine to Poland then Ireland and
eventually America where they'd reunite
with her father but it was family she
found through the sport of hockey a
beloved Pastime in the state where they
settled that helped not just Margot but
the whole family start to feel like
they'd found their new home
it's a scene played out and rinks all
across Minnesota kids of all ages
gliding and grinding it out in the
official state sport hockey and how long
have you guys all been playing hockey
[Applause]
[Music]
I've been playing
Freya Elsa Megan and Ellie have
basically been born into the sport
playing for a combined 10 years longer
than any have been alive Millers go down
to the obstacle course with Coach Vlad
all are members of the Minneapolis storm
Aiden under Youth Hockey League and this
year they welcomed in a new teammate
I'll go
Margo vestigeva
what do you love about this
Katie
it's just so fun I I can't explain
Margo not just new to the team in sport
but also the country
and Ukrainian can't play attack you
cause just Boys Hockey and here
everybody gets to play yeah
when the war broke out in Ukraine last
year she and her mom Anastasia like so
many others fled
Crossing into Poland at this border we
go and we not understand what we do in
future where we live I have just one bag
he left with one bag yes
and to his dog because we have Dockers
yeah and some document
may not bring with us nothing and it's
so sad because I love my my life
margot's father Igor had been working in
the United States for several years but
told us Anastasia couldn't get a Visa so
she and Margot couldn't join him even
when the war broke out it took about
seven months and a multi-country journey
before they were reunited I came here
because you know I need I need to get
some work for family okay so I'm working
here on Saint Monica all this time
we hope that we will United
finally it happens you know so bad
things in my country so
it just create a way to unite my family
while Margo was forced to leave Ukraine
without basic needs and Comforts like
clothing and toys one thing she always
had with her was her love of music
finding a way to play and practice piano
wherever she could
though here in Minneapolis it has a bit
of competition
use that box
she wouldn't have played in Ukraine no
no but here she play yeah and she loves
it maybe she loves more
hockey's and play piano yeah is that
true you love hockey more than piano
but getting Margot started in hockey
took a little bit of help after she
showed her mom this Hockey League flyer
recruiting new players and apparently
they'd only been here for a couple weeks
at that point like in Minneapolis so she
was new to her Elementary School she was
new to Minnesota Minneapolis the USA and
she was like I want to try hockey all
the way around all the way around two
days on your stick coach Drew Woods says
that's when the hockey Community rallied
springing into action after hearing from
Margo's mom and so immediately I
responded to her and like four other
people from the association was like we
need to do this how do we cut all the
red tape and make this like something
that happens because there's a lot of
barriers to entry yeah the hockey mean
like birth certificate you know like
that's hard for us to all come up with
how can we make this affordable and how
can we make this actually accessible and
doable that help also included brand new
hockey gear from head to toe and it was
like you know what like she doesn't need
to use our second hand stuff let's make
this special let's go to the hockey
store with her and let's just like get
her good stuff brand new in like this
sort of fresh
[Laughter]
I know Margo's won
watching the world unravel in lots of
strange ways in in from our couches and
we can only do so much
and so when a part of that world that's
in turmoil knocks on your door and says
like can I come in yeah we're gonna do
that I wish more people could enjoy it
with us and so when you get one person
in the door that also increases the
appetite to get more people in the door
and as you see it out here today like
she's no guest here anymore
she was saying like these are her
friends now this has helped her right
fit in right and as it turns out Margo's
not the only one who's found a community
Through hockey you're a hockey mom now
yes it's family community was family
some people help meet Transportation
pick up me and margosha with this big
bag in hockey and back at home
because I not have a car I love this
community hockey community in Minnesota
do you think here is a place where you
can start to build a life again this is
a place to to be home again it's like
the words I wanna play hockey let's go
everything possible so everything
possible here
yeah
all right
it was it's hard not to smile about the
way everybody came together and people
are like birth certificate what do you
need this is part of USA Hockey so there
really are anybody's got a kid in hockey
gets it there's so many rules and
everybody did what they needed to to
help you may have heard in the beginning
coach Vlad there's actually a coach on
the team who has ties back to Russia
through his family he's able to also
help with communication wish them all
the best of luck just a great story it's
a beautiful Story the fact I mean look
at what they've been through in the past
year in a family that has just create
been created around them wonderful I
love when she says skating and scoring
goals it's all fun I can't explain yeah
you just did I know she was wonderful I
loved Margo and wonderful